ابني حكم عليه بالإعدام
هو 20 فقط 22.
ابني بريء من حب الله
ساعده
العائلات اليائسة في إيران مخاطرة
بكل شيء مع مناشدة للعالم لإنقاذ
أحبائهم من الإعدام
خوفا من أن يقال عن المعتقلين في
إيران  نواجه موجة من عمليات الإعدام في
عملية قضائية متسارعة بينما
تحظى الاحتفالات بالأعياد
باهتمام العالم في أماكن أخرى بالتعاون
مع مجموعة الناشطين الإيرانيين 1500 tasveer ،
ونحن نعمل على التحقق من وثائق المحكمة التي
تظهر أن عشرات الإيرانيين بما في ذلك
الرياضيون الإيرانيون البارزون يواجهون
الإعدام.  تحقق من الفيديو من
فضلك مثل هذا من هذه
الأم البالغة من العمر 81 عامًا لأحد المحتجزين ،
ولا نعرف مكان وجوده ولا توجد
معلومات عنه ولا حتى
نعرف مكانه. هذه الوثيقة من
داخل محكمة أصفهان الإقليمية تظهر
أن 10 أشخاص على الأقل  تم
اتهامهم بحرب المحاربة على الله
ونشر الفساد في الأرض وتهم أخرى
كلها تحمل
احتمالية قلم الموت.  من
خلال الحصول على وثائق المحكمة والتحقق منها
وشهادة الشهود ، لدينا
أدلة تدعم تسريع
الإجراءات القضائية.
تعتقد عائلات إيرانية مذعورة أنه في الوقت الذي ينشغل فيه العالم
بالاحتفال بموسم الأعياد مشغول مع
عائلاتهم ، فإنهم في إيران يواجهون
الإعدام الوشيك لأحبائهم ،
وقد أكدت سي إن إن أن
لاعب كرة القدم الإيراني عامر ناصر آزاداني من بين
أولئك الذين يواجهون الإعدام هنا.
يتدرب قبل يوم المباراة الآن
ينتظر تنفيذ حكم الإعدام فيه ، هذا
مقطع فيديو على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي من ليلة اعتقاله ، اتصلت سي إن إن
بشخص مقرب من ناصر
آزاداني داخل إيران ، ولم نكشف
عن هويته ، وأخبرونا
أنه في الأيام التي أعقبت اعتقاله.
لم نتمكن من الحصول على كلمة منه أو
عنه من مؤلفي  العلاقات حتى مع
نفي السلطات الإيرانية اعتقاله ،
فقد كان شهرًا واحدًا و 19 يومًا ، أعتقد أنه
ربما يكون أكثر من ذلك منذ أن
جاءت قوات الأمن وأرادت رؤية
منازل الأمير ،
وعلى الرغم من إخبارنا بأنه سيطلق سراحه ،
فقد أخبرونا في أول بضعة أيام.
بعد أسابيع من إطلاق سراح أمير وإطلاق سراح أمير
بنهاية الأسبوع ،
ثم وجهت إليه تهمة جريمة
حرب المحاربة على الله
التي اتهم ناصر آزاداني وتسعة أشخاص
آخرين بالتورط
في قتل اثنين من الباسيج.
عناصر من الميليشيات وأحد رجال الشرطة خلال
العملية في أواخر نوفمبر / تشرين الثاني ، التهمة التي
ينفونها الآن تقول مصادر مقربة من ناصر أ.
غرب أصفهان
أكدت CNN مع 1500 tasveer الذي
اقتبس من الوثائق أن 23 شخصًا آخر قد
اتهموا بنفس الجريمة
التي يُعاقب عليها بالإعدام.  حذف
أسمائهم خوفًا على
سلامتهم ، لا يزال هناك المزيد من تشجيع CNN
وقد أكد 1500 tasveer أن
خمسة إيرانيين آخرين على الأقل يواجهون
الإعدام ، بما في ذلك بطل الكاراتيه الإيراني الكردي البالغ من العمر 21 عامًا
والذي أعلن والديه أيضًا
عن
سرورهما ، أرجوك أتوسل إليكم.  لإلغاء
أمر الإعدام من حياة ابني
في الرسائل التي تمت مشاركتها مع سي إن إن ،
تقول عائلته إن كريمي لم يُحكم عليه
بالإعدام فحسب ، بل إنه يتعرض أيضًا للتعذيب في
السجن
في رسالة أخرى تمت مشاركتها مع شبكة سي إن إن ، قالوا
إن كريمي كان في حالة معنوية جيدة بطريقة ما
ولكنه أصيب بأضرار جسدية  عانى من
التعذيب على رأسه وجسده ،
بمن فيهم أولئك الذين سجلت عائلاتهم
مناشدات علنية للمساعدة ، ما يرفع
إجمالي من تحققت منهم سي إن إن بأنهم يواجهون
الإعدام إلى 43 على الأقل ،
بالإضافة إلى الاثنين اللذين أعدمتهما إيران
وسط الإثارة في المونديال
الإيراني.  حاول مشهد مغني الراب الكردي سمانية
الانتحار أثناء احتجازه
بحسب مصدر من السجن
حاولت أن تنهي حياته تقول مصادر
مع الحبوب بعد
تعرضه للتعذيب النفسي الشديد في ظروف
السجن القاسية في شمال إيران حيث
يستوعب الكثير من العالم
باحتفالاتهم العائلات الإيرانية لديها
رسالة واحدة
يرجى حفظها لمحبة الله ،
حفظ أبنائي
لندن